hi my name is Daniel Pham and welcome to
this week in Android development for
Monday November eighteenth 2013 both
ready to a Meyer and not wait to admire
are indisposed this week so I'll be
taking the reins and providing your
weekly dose of updates today last week
metal marine released another dead bite
in Portuguese or faithful teammates
presented various talks at devoxx in
Belgium and rato grazed and def con in
san francisco with the keynote speech
delivered in this charming natural New
Zealander accent this week game on is
back from hiatus Todd returns from his
short stint working on top secret
projects to celebrate the half birthday
of play games in app update news and
doors got a fresh tablet UI with
chromecast integration while ski safari
has updated to include play games
integration leaderboards and cloud sync
that's all for this week in Android
development be sure to check out our
shows this week I'm Daniel Pham and that
kind of luxe just ain't for us we crave
a different kind of buzz